[Music]
three
two one action what up guys welcome back
to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we
want and it's the end of the year and
usually at the end of the year
of most years people start thinking
about what do they want to do
next year and i feel like this year
because all of us
been hella restricted from all kinds of
stuff we probably have a lot of goals
for next year what are some of your
guys's all my goals is play dude
like what is it okay you want to see the
pyramids i'm gonna
i'm gonna i don't know if i can go
international
but for sure we gotta do our over
landing
trip where we all go off-roading for a
couple days hell yeah and we live in the
wilderness oh that'd be so tight uh
definitely want to snowboard a lot this
year cause it's gotta make we gotta make
up
for like the i haven't snowboarded in
three years oh [ __ ] yeah 2017 was the
last time i went i think last year i did
snowboard movie once or twice
but not enough yeah and we used to go
like every week man
so that's something i want to do again
and bring back into my life
so definitely that i want to go
van lifeing again because i have a good
relationship with the cuckoo campers
company now
so they're like yeah whenever you're in
colorado take us out
oh it's only in colorado well that's
where their hub is
they're gonna open up more locations but
um that's where their main
like places and then i can basically
take it anywhere as long as i don't
cross into canada or mexico
oh [ __ ] yeah a few years ago we visited
one of our athletes in colorado
and we saw like was it elk or deer
i think elk it was like we're just
driving down the street and there's just
like
moose moose and there's [ __ ] hundreds
of them and no
[ __ ] like if i'm standing straight up
the ass is where my face is
damn like they weigh like 2 000 pounds
and they're just
[ __ ] hundreds of them and like i
wanted to get close
are they nice i don't know i wanted to
get close but they look so big that if i
made one wrong move
they'll just turn their head and their
[ __ ] antler would knock you out yeah
it's like a
foot like maybe like six foot antlers
they look like
they look buffer than horses and bigger
than horses i'd do it if i had armor on
and then i can pet them with my bare
hand
like knight's armor yeah i'll have
knight's armor but then i'll i'll pitch
him
yeah i wish we could like domesticate
them and ride them like horses
that'll be so sick can you just hold on
to the antler and nobody [ __ ] with you
there's this tribe i want to visit in
mongolia where it's like
siberia mongolia um there's a
they they they raise reindeer and they
ride them
oh that's thai and then they it's like
some epic ass like reindeer
horse kind of things and they eat them
like raw
yeah i saw some parts in like mongolia
too where they were right into the
cafeteria
yo this one i was watching this one
other show
uh i forgot what it was but um there's
these kids
that are in mongolia and how they
because you know they're like nomadic
yeah and so how they were traveling they
pretty much just have this little baby
mongolian baby
tied straight up onto the reindeer with
like 300 ropes
damn strapped on so it's impossible to
fall off and you just see this baby like
like all smiling and laughing i always
see [ __ ] like that and like
in other countries the baby never
complains yeah they're like [ __ ] it
you know this is this is they're like
they know their responsibilities [ __ ]
spoiled ass babies here this baby had
responsibilities already the mom's like
hey i'm gonna cook right now and uh so
they're cooking in you know those
mongolian tents
so the baby who's probably like i don't
know
four or five so not a baby
it looked like a baby to me this baby
grabbed another baby and said hey you're
gonna come help me
so they're both carrying a pot in each
hand and they go to the part where the
snow is the freshest and they collect
the snow
so that they can not the yellow snow no
no nothing else they can bring it back
so the mom can melt it and make soup
dang
damn look at taika my men's photo
actually does help jio cook though never
mind
i saw him [ __ ] washing vegetables he
actually really likes helping
just pretty cool there was this uh one
guy that went into
this really remote area in africa and he
stayed with this tribe
and one thing that he noticed was like
there was no crying like from the babies
like at night he was like it's so weird
that at night
you know you're used to babies waking
everybody up but there's no crying
nothing
that's dope yeah but there's a ton of
kids though so he was just like why is
this happening like
how come it doesn't how come there's no
babies crying in the middle of the night
all the babies probably licking dmt or
something they're just tripping out
they're like i got teddy milk
come on if i go now the babies just got
[ __ ]
toad juice in them just tranquilizer
that's what's crazy is like all these
other countries
like they do some crazy stuff like um i
was in thailand
and i saw this whole family like with
the babies i mean in vietnam too but
they'll ride
like on the scooter with like a mom and
a kid
and a baby and then just [ __ ] roll
like that
i i saw like a golden retriever like on
somebody like a backpack and then they
were riding
it was crazy man it's [ __ ] crazy
but i guess out here we're like
extra senses i don't know how many laws
and you get sued yeah maybe we reduce
infancy for uh death or whatever too i
don't know
yeah i think it's more of like uh how do
you call it like
caring like we have the luxury to be
more comfortable
so we don't have to make our kids do
those things yeah like they don't have
to work
to survive at a young age yeah they
don't have to go collect fresh water
yeah that's true because like
back in the day they used to pop out a
lot of kids out here
to work on the farm so they can have
help and in case one of them died or
something
yeah i was uh i was watching just the
evolution of human beings and how we
came to be
in terms of just how we walk and
everything but like as like the the
primates started to like walk and
get off all fours like and start to walk
normally
um as we became more erect
our waste became smaller uh so the
babies they came out more premature
that's why babies only come out nine
months and we have to care for them
longer
oh so there's actually supposed to stay
in there for like like a year or two i
don't know about that but in terms of
how much they're able to grow
can you imagine a taika popping out of a
human being
dang but then that's why like other
animals they're
walking that day yeah that's true so
like like bambi and [ __ ] yes like humans
are the only ones that uh
for years have to take care of the
babies because through evolution they
came out more premature
oh damn if the if if a human is supposed
to pop out and supposed to walk like a
deer
because i think humans start walking at
eight months that means they're supposed
to be in there twice as long
what about monkeys are they premature
too
not necessarily uh in terms of length
but just development in the womb
yeah um and that's why we have like
smaller heads or whatever
but um babies are also able to clean
like
super young primates cling on to their
mothers and like
can like crawl and walk babies too yeah
like little babies they have some of
their strongest strength like if you
take a newborn and you put it like on
like a
narrow bar they can just hold on
like this is your brand this is the
baby's branch like they could just hold
on to you
yeah like a parrot i think they're
supposed to just hold on and just
so strong man it was weird i was talking
about even about like
how when we first discovered fire and
cooked meat it was easier to chew
so then our mandibles and our like
wisdom teeth we treat it back in and
some people are starting like
over time those teeth won't they'll just
disappear
in like primates are out right because
they needed to chew it because they
don't cook their own food
so just learning the history of that
that's why like if you look at other
cultures and stuff like that that's why
maybe
sometimes backup teeth yeah we literally
do yeah
damn that's nuts but for 2021 i think
i'm gonna
i'm definitely gonna travel to mongolia
do more things that i'm already doing
now but on steroids
yeah oh there's another thing is i'm
gonna uh next year when bart moves to
vegas i'm gonna visit him
through the back route through the
desert on just off-road vehicles
is it like a definite battle to get
there like you know how to follow it
people do it
yeah yeah like i don't know if i'm gonna
do that on motorcycles yet or on
off-road vehicles
but definitely i'm gonna show up dusty
to his house
i'll be tight maybe you could hit me up
and i'll try to meet you halfway
that'll be cool yeah i do see people
camp and they'll set up like little fire
pits and then since it's like
technically all like blm land like
people they they shoot and do all kinds
of fun stuff in the middle i'll be
really tight
i think for me i uh i for sure want to
travel
but since i don't know if international
will be open
um one thing i am really looking forward
forward to
is road trips because like i think with
having taika it's just
easier to be in like one self-contained
vehicle
and whenever i need to i could take a
break but when we did the rv trip and
stuff i think we went to grand canyon we
went through lake havasu that was cool
and then we went to yosemite through on
my truck and that's cool
and i think one thing i always wanted to
do was
uh go to like all the national parks and
like cities and buy like those little
patches
and just put it like all inside so like
i can go oh cool i've been
sedona i've been salt lake city i've
been wherever
would you get an rv or a van or a like
pickup truck with
like like off-road capabilities or like
i think
my goal for like the family adventure
vehicle would be to get probably either
like a
a newer land cruiser or a tahoe because
i think uh suv is just easier
yeah plus the new ones are dope because
you can have like
the tv in the back for the kids yeah and
like if they want to watch like hbo
like uh they could israel max yeah
that's cool they got some of the best
shows you know the rated r stuff for the
children is the best i'm just kidding
shout outs to hbo max for sponsoring off
the record because
this holiday season everyone's trying to
spend time with their families get cozy
and snuggle up and try to stay safe so
they have some of the best movies for
people to watch
if you're into christmas movies like i
am they got some of the best ones like
last christmas the family stone
holiday affair a christmas carol and if
you like seeing bloodshed during
christmas
they also have gladiator buzz shauna the
dead
they have billy elliot true grit
sex in the city if you like that even
actual sex news is actually really
really good they have all kinds of stuff
so some of the best movies are out there
and if you like euphoria they have a
euphoria special so they pretty much
have
all of the best shows and movies so this
season if you're trying to spend time
and be safe and quarantine with your
family or your crew for the holidays
hbo max has the most bingeable series
for you just go to https colinford slash
hbom.ax off the record to get cozy at
home this holiday season
thank you hbo max
what are your goals for 2021 um honestly
i just want to for me like
like set up some businesses or work and
like the things that i want to do
so finally like last weekend i started
filming for like my cooking show like
the way i wanted to
oh so it's cool and then uh so i start
releasing some
within like a week or two you already
have a few episodes then i shot three
episodes oh [ __ ] yeah and then next year
hopefully the beginning of the year i
start the drunk cooking series
and then that's like uh something that
will be pretty big but
uh i feel like just taking the time and
just like
one major thing would be like smarter
for me instead of like trying to like do
so many goals
yeah because i already will travel i
already will do that's true
um that i've been continuing to do i
think just with like
realizing i think through this year
realizing how much easier it is to
um work um so like i don't want to add
those to my goals
but definitely like just setting up a
like a business as my own would be
really dope that's really dope yeah
is there something that uh for your
cooking show that you set up that you're
like
oh this is really cool or like what's
the thing that you're like the most
excited or most proud of the thing
because i've always liked doing things
that like with like the comedy stuff
just making people laugh or bringing
some type of like entertainment
but with cooking i noticed so many
people would like post like their steaks
or just anything and tag me and it was
like a direct relationship with people
that can like
actually see them impacting my life and
theirs
um so that was like a cool way of just
setting that up where i'm actually
teaching people
so like cook how to cook yeah so that's
like uh as much as i'm learning i just
want to try to like give that back and
that's like my favorite
thing that i'm trying to set up with
like the cooking shows that's tight you
have uh
how many cameras you have set up too we
just we shot four four cameras
four cameras yeah because before it was
literally just me on a tripod and i
would move that around and the views
were great like i was like
getting like it was between like for the
cooking stuff like 50 to 150 000 views
dude your your steak one went viral yeah
when that one've been
the dollar stake yeah i did two so then
um one one got to a million one got to
like six hundred thousand
that's crazy but then that's why i
stopped because i didn't want to get
known for those gimmicky stuff
oh the money was so good the views were
so good but then i
like i've seen my friends that got
famous off of one thing
and then they hated their lives because
they can't do anything else because
their fans only want to see that
so i nipped it in the butt early isn't
that crazy yeah so i
luckily i saw that but i nipped in the
butt so i didn't want to get caught up
in making the money
and like the views and just being known
for that imagine how dog face feels
they're like everyone just hand them
cranbraiders drink this i just want to
drink water sometimes
yeah yeah he's drinking water fat goes
no no not a skateboard everywhere you go
cranberry juice yeah skateboard if
they're paying him hella money coming
from where he came from i'm sure he's
hella that's true he's like i'll drink
crabs
all day can you imagine people cheering
because you drank
juice yeah that's kind of nice
that's dope he it in the most peaceful
and chill way though i know
so you're gonna do the the cooking show
was a hard film did you film yourself we
had help
i had four people four cameras or four
people
three so one was a wide they didn't need
help then i had uh
uh their buddy chris yeah darian and
then our
uh buddy justin so it's like did you
film it at darien's place yeah
also it's probably gonna look dope then
yeah like there's already definitely
things that we can improve on but that's
the first
first few episodes it's so tight so then
um from there just trying to like
push out that type of content and like
do things that
make me happy plus also i think one of
the other goals is just like
work smarter you know like realizing
like okay if i get the work done
easier do this do that i don't have to
work as hard
for the same results yeah so i want to
like definitely chill out a bit more
next year without like
chill out my brain yeah yeah not like
stress too much about that
it's weird i'm producing more stuff now
like i'm posting like every other day on
my
channel for like the last month now like
that's tight
yeah but i don't feel busier yeah
because i think as you're doing the
things that you like compared to
being like i gotta film something oh
that's true like i have so much footage
and it's like hitter after hitter like
having fun content
i'm not like forced to make it yeah so
that we've all came from that style
where it was like just you have to do
this type of content you have to like
get content out yeah keep coming up with
it instead of things that are mostly
just like
um because they're all fun but they're
like work too yeah and sometimes when it
doesn't feel like as much work
it comes out even better yeah things are
a little bit more passionate about yeah
because you've been like doing so much
this year
yeah and it doesn't feel like work
because
everything is kind of new and it's play
and even
even like right now i'm um getting an
investment property with my friends
and we're gonna start doing airbnb
rental spots
and it's so easy like it's it's
not difficult in a sense where it's not
stressful it's exciting you know
and i mean none of this stuff should be
really i think that uh
when you're in a bad state of
mind everything becomes negative and
stressful
but then when you're like if you're
going through the same [ __ ]
i mean it's like youtube or jk news are
doing the same things
but just a shift in how you see the
things and how your life is
uh it it just makes the world of a
difference like it just makes things
really fun and exciting again yeah
that's tight oh yeah one thing i had of
a goal for that actually started this
year
during the quarantine was uh this year i
actually wanted to write a children's
book
and um i didn't get to because of like
you know the whole shutdown so like a
lot of the businesses we have to
brainstorm what are we gonna do
and then when i was quarantined on kovid
my first i think four or five days i
just binge watched cobra kai
and that's how i started texting you all
the stuff i was like oh i know what
you're talking about
okay yeah yeah and then after i watch
both of those sho uh both seasons
um i think like and i started to feel
feel better
i was like oh it's something i could do
that's kind of creative and i think i
started taking those like funny pictures
with like the figure yeah
and then i'm like oh i just started
working on the children's book now
and then so i started writing it and
actually had the first draft written oh
cool
yeah it just i just um i wrote it pretty
quickly
and so hopefully next year i can like
get it on like
amazon or something is that why you've
been drawing on it like is it a coloring
book or what
no it's just a uh so what i like this i
like
uh stories growing up like the tortoise
and the hair where it teaches like a
cool lesson yeah
so like i feel like there's some lessons
that um aren't emphasized as much in
this day and age i think like everyone
is like super woke now and everyone
knows a lot about their own emotions and
intelligence
but you know how like analysis is
paralysis where i feel like people have
a hard time like
like taking the first step and just
sometimes there's just merit to just
putting her head down and then working
hard so
i i tied it into uh the book's gonna be
called monkey and the cheese
because monkey and the cheese yeah cause
uh monkey i always call taika monkey
dude
so it's kind of like uh i guess the same
lesson i would wanna teach him
i wrote it into a story yeah yeah and
then his favorite word is cheese all the
time
why i don't know he just likes it so
there's a lot of like insider like
between my relationship with him so it's
called monkey and the cheese
and it's about this little monkey that
needs to make a cheese
sandwich for his mom for his birthday
but he opens the refrigerator and
there's no cheese in it so he has to go
through like
all these like hoops to buy cheese they
finally get the cheese so that he can
make it
just get like really dark and no no it's
children it's a blow like a
like a crack head for money doesn't go
that extra
it's a children's book it teaches uh
like kids like
like the monkey's gonna have obstacles
right and it teaches the kids to like
like try and solve the problem don't
just give up
yeah like if you want something yeah if
you want something you have to
like go all out and get it and yeah it's
called monkey
i thought you would have wrote something
like more on brand with bar like tony
the little [ __ ] or something
that could be part two little [ __ ] tony
little [ __ ] tony little [ __ ] tony's
like i can't make the cheese pizza
yeah no no that'd be funny yeah it's
called mike and it
it rhymes and [ __ ] too that's cool man
did you draw it and [ __ ] too
no no oh you gotta add pictures man
that's definitely
kids like it's just gonna be it's gonna
be a novice like the [ __ ]
you crazy i'm not gonna read a book with
no pictures
no that's the hard part where like um
you know when you have a novel
it's just all words right so pretty much
after you're done writing you're done
when i was done pretty much 90 of the
dialogue
i mean like the the the text i'm like oh
[ __ ] now i have to write
a paragraph per page so that whoever's
gonna illustrate knows what the hell i
want happening on
the page and i'm like why don't you draw
it you have
dope ass art skills look at that [ __ ]
sun with gloves back there dude
arts that's yours you do that yeah kids
man
we used to draw like characters this one
would draw
a flower stop sign with a hard boner and
[ __ ]
i don't know if that's for kids that's
just crazy no that's not definitely not
the [ __ ] kid
[Music]
you